[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the sarah lawrence sex cult scandal
isabella pollock was the only
co-defendant that prosecutors charged
with larry ray in the sensational
college sex cult case
law and crimes adam classfeld is at the
federal courthouse as isabella pollack
enters a plea and could elizabeth holmes
receive a new trial why the convicted
fraudster says she deserves one plus a
music journalist credited with breaking
the r kelly scandal fights a defense
subpoena requiring him to testify and
later the death of eliza fletcher the
heiress's accused murderer appears in
court for a second arraignment law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
larry ray's only co-defendant in the
so-called sarah lawrence sex cult case
pleads guilty to her role in the scheme
long crime network managing editor adam
classfeld was in the courtroom when
isabella pollock entered a play
this is a daniel patrick moynihan
courthouse in the background where just
hours earlier 15 stories high we had the
sole co-defendant in the larry ray sarah
lawrence sex cult case plead guilty to a
charge of conspiring against the united
states by laundering larry ray's money
the object of the money laundering
conspiracy was hiding the proceeds of
sex trafficking and extortion and
isabella pollock 31 years old admitted
to that count in court
isabella pollack was the only
co-defendant that prosecutors charged
with larry ray in the sensational
college sex cult case
one of larry ray's victims claudia drury
testified that she made 2.5 million
dollars in enforced prostitution had to
turn over the proceeds to larry ray and
isabella pollack by her guilty plea
today admitted to being
part of that conspiracy to extort larry
ray's victims and to sexually traffick
uh claudia drury she is going to be
sentenced in february the maximum
penalty that she's facing is five years
in jail and that is also her federal
sentencing guidelines five years of
imprisonment this is adam classfield for
the law and crime network
all right joining us today is co-host
terry austin and criminal defense
attorney marie pereira great to have you
both here maria start with you you know
we don't often see defendants plead
guilty why do you think she pled guilty
here because she got the sweetest deal
ever
she sat down with her attorneys and they
probably told her exactly what they had
against her all the evidence that the
prosecutors wanted to present against
her at trial and there probably was a
very meticulous money trail proving that
she assisted him in hiding the money
and so she did what was best and she
pled guilty based on advice from her
counsel terry marie's making a good
point i mean larry ray was found guilty
of 15 counts including sex trafficking
and he faces a mandatory minimum of 15
years of maximum sentence of life do you
think five years for paula given
everything that she did is fair i don't
i think she should have gotten more
considering the nature of the crime look
she pled guilty to conspiracy to money
laundering but the underlying crimes
that she was supporting with that plea
were sex trafficking and extortion those
are very serious crimes she was actually
considered ray's top lieutenant and
there was so much evidence against her
they had witness testimony financial
records they even had videos and so i
definitely think they should have thrown
the book at her even though the sentence
is consistent with the guidelines i
think that there was room here to go
even higher and
quite frankly i think that all in all
it's fair but i don't think that it's
sufficient this was something that we
want to try to make sure it doesn't
happen again yeah and there are these
kind of eerie similarities when you talk
about jeffrey epstein and galaine
maxwell and look you know pleading
guilty you save the expense and the
heartache of a trial as well and i think
that has to become into consideration as
well when you talk about the
sensitivities and the trauma of this
kind of case
well children and teachers returned to
school for a new year in uvalde texas
nearly four months after a gunman
entered rob elementary school with a
rifle and killed 21 students and faculty
it was the deadliest school massacre in
almost a decade when 19 students and two
teachers were shot and killed by an
18-year-old gunman on may 24th earlier
this year students returning for the new
year will not be resuming classes inside
rob elementary as there are plans to in
place to tear down the building and many
students and teachers have been spread
out among other uvalde school district
buildings some second and third graders
have left the school district entirely
while others receive scholarships for
nearby private schools and this all
comes as five department of public
safety officers are being investigated
and two have been suspended following
the heavily scrutinized police response
to the shooting as law enforcement
waited over an hour to engage with the
gunman the office of inspector general
will determine if the officers in fact
violated policy nearly 400 law
enforcement officers responded to the
massacre still ahead on law and crime
daily the defense continues its case as
disgraced r b singer r kelly stands
federal trial in illinois but first
could elizabeth holmes receive a new
trial ahead of the former theranos ceo
sentencing holmes petitioned the court
for a new trial
[Music]
back everybody theranos fraudster
elizabeth holmes is demanding a new
trial this comes after a bombshell claim
that a prosecution witness showed up to
her house to say he regretted his
testimony in january holmes was
convicted of federal fraud charges she
had claimed that her biotech company
would revolutionize medicine but it
turned out to be a giant fraud which
scams several people out of millions of
dollars in a new court filing holm's
attorney says that a former theronos lab
director who was a key witness for the
government at her trial went to her home
in early august unannounced he
reportedly claims his testimony had been
twisted by prosecutors and that he tried
to answer honestly but says the
government tried to make everyone look
bad holmes's attorney argues this
warrants a new trial or at the very
least an evidentiary hearing to call the
lab director to testify about his
concerns the former ceo has yet to be
sentenced that's scheduled to happen
september 26th holmes faces up to 20
years behind bars and up to 250 000
dollars plus restitution for each count
terry so you have this key government
witness now has a change of heart is
that enough to overturn the conviction
get a new trial
jesse as my law school professor used to
say
too bad so sad it is not a grounds for
getting a new trial listen the grounds
for an appeal are relatively limited in
a case like this you can have legal
error obviously meaning that some
evidence was improperly admitted or you
know you can have jury instructions that
weren't quite correct or that weren't
included you can have jury misconduct
none of that exists here i mean you can
even have ineffective assistance of
counsel resulting in some sort of legal
error we don't have that here all we
have is a witness who theoretically was
supposed to be testifying truthfully so
as long as he testified truthfully he
can now claim that it's not right it's
not fair the prosecution has a right to
argue the case
and again too bad so sad you know you
should have
talked to the prosecution beforehand i
mean i've never heard it before and
marie you focus on holmes for a second
she was found guilty of conspiracy to
commit wire fraud plus three counts of
wire fraud she faces up to 20 years
behind bars for each count do you think
the imposition of the maximum sentence
would be justified here
i don't think it would be but then again
there will be a pre-plea sentencing
report
and probation is going to interview her
they're going to look at her criminal
history they're going to interview her
the victims that potentially were
impacted by this big lie
and the judge is going to have to come
up with a number i don't think max is
going to be what happens to her simply
because she just doesn't have an
extensive criminal history
i'd say i agree with you but i have been
surprised before uh aka the harvey
weinstein trial with 23 years in prison
when you really didn't have that kind of
criminal record obviously very different
case but this is also a very differing
case a kind of a fraud that we've never
really heard like this before so we'll
wait and see how much time she will
spend behind bars well over now in new
york former adviser to president donald
trump steve bannon is expected to turn
himself into prosecutors thursday to
face a new criminal indictment the state
charges reportedly stemmed from previous
federal charges that trump had pardoned
him for surrounding fundraising and
alleged defrauding of donors for the
will you build the wall campaign he was
accused of pocketing a million dollars
in the alleged scheme presidential
pardons only apply to federal charges so
bannon can be charged at the state level
this all comes weeks after the former
top strategist was convicted of contempt
of congress for refusing to cooperate
with the white house committee
investigating the january 6 u.s capital
attack and that he ignored a
congressional subpoena that he was
legally obligated to answer
switching now to nevada where las vegas
officials released new images of the
suspect connected with a veteran
reporter's stabbing death
sixty-nine-year-old jeff german a
veteran reporter for the las vegas
review journal was found stabbed to
death outside of his home on september
third authorities received a 911 phone
call at about 10 30 that morning the
next day a medical examiner determined
german died of quote multiple sharp
force injuries ruling his death a
homicide police believe german got into
an altercation with someone that
resulted in the stabbing they also say
that the suspect was likely casing the
neighborhood to commit other crimes
since german's death the las vegas
police department has released a series
of images they believe are connected to
the murder the photos and video show a
person wearing what appears to be a
straw hat and an orange reflective
jacket you see right there and
surveillance video also shows a maroon
gmc yukon denali that police say could
be connected to the crime investigators
are now working to identify the person
in the video and the owner of the
vehicle
coming up on long crime daily
back-to-back court hearings for the
tennessee man investigators say abducted
and murdered an heiress schoolteacher
plus a long-time reporter covering the r
kelly case argues he shouldn't have to
take the stand we take a closer look at
the writer's argument
[Music]
welcome back r kelly's defense picks up
their case in the federal sex crimes
trial as the judge rules a former
chicago sometimes journalist will not
have to testify for the defense 55 year
old kelly a convicted sex offender now
stands trial in illinois on federal sex
crimes charges back in 2008 the singer
was acquitted of charges for creating a
video of himself having sex with a 14
year old now at the time the alleged
victim and her family denied their
involvement but 16 years later the
accuser and her mother testified for the
prosecution saying they lied about their
involvement after kelly threatened them
reporter jim derogatis has followed
kelly's case for years saying he
anonymously received a video that helped
lead to kelly's 2008 child pornography
trial that same video has been entered
as evidence in kelly's current federal
trial in court documents filed tuesday
derogators argued that he shouldn't have
to testify for the defense and on
wednesday the case's judge agreed also
on wednesday kelly's former business
manager and co-defendant darrell mcdavid
took the stand mcdavid testified that he
didn't believe early sexual assault
allegations about kelly saying it was
the cost of doing business in the
entertainment industry
well marie the judge ruled that
derogators didn't have to testify
because the tape was already
authenticated by another witness is that
standard operating procedure is that the
right decision
it's the right decision and generally
appellate courts have ruled forcing a
journalist to testify about cases
they've covered should be a rare and
last resort in this case it's already
been authenticated so the chain of
custody issues don't exist and
it would be pointless to force him to
testify
and you know what there was also an
issue of safety on the 2008 trial where
kelly was acquitted
he testified in that case and received
death threats so why put the man through
that again
terry this trial is a lot different
right so you have daryl mcdavid he's a
co-defendant in this case he testified
that he didn't believe the claims
against kelly were true
you think the jury should just trust him
i mean this is a this is an important
witness
listen if i'm sitting in that jury i am
going to be skeptical of mcdavid's
testimony remember he's kelly's former
business manager so he was part and
parcel of everything that went on like
you said he testified that he thought
those early accusations were extortion
and the fact that many of the cases were
settled and it was less than the
original demand he thought that that
meant they were definitely not true and
i think it's callous for him to go on to
say that it was something as you know
simple as the cost of doing business
basically it's saying that you can do
anything you want as long as you can get
it paid off so i think that jury should
be careful they're going to get a jury
instruction that says the witness
depending on his relationship could very
well have somebody
it's an interesting argument that we've
actually heard before in these kinds of
cases so yeah we'll see how it shakes up
heading south to florida where
investigators say a couple lured a 14
year old into their apartment to play
spin the bottle before sexually
assaulting her investigators say 23 year
old emmanuel martinez and 18 year old
jocelyn gomez now face multiple charges
including sexual battery on a child over
the age of 12 and lewd and lascivious
exhibition on a child under age 16.
officials say gomez knew the 14 year old
girl from school and originally invited
her to go to the movies when gomez and
martinez picked the girl up from her
home they changed plans and instead went
to their apartment that's where
investigators say the pair asked the
girl to play spin the bottle officials
say the pair pressured the girl to take
off her clothes and kiss martinez which
she denied after that martinez allegedly
forced the girl down and raped her as
gomez watched the couple were arrested
last friday and police say martinez
confessed to the crimes
when we come back the murder of heiress
teacher and mother eliza fletcher the
man accused of abduction abducting
fletcher appears in court for the second
time this week but will he make bond
that's still ahead on long crime daily
[Music]
welcome back everybody testimony resume
wednesday in the california case of paul
and ruben flores as the father and son
stand trial for the disappearance and
death of kristin smart 26 years ago the
cal poly student went missing after a
party in may of 1996 but the case went
cold for two decades with very few leads
paul and ruben flores were long
suspected in the case and were arrested
last year following several searches of
their homes witnesses say paul who's
charged with her murder was the last
person seen with smart when he walked
her home from the party paul's father
reuben is charged with accessory after
the fact for allegedly helping hide the
body and allegedly burying her in his
backyard and later moving the remains on
wednesday the state continued presenting
its case before two separate juries one
for paul and another for reuben the day
got off to a delayed start as a
scheduled witness fell ill
shelby liddell a forensic specialist
continued her testimony from last week
telling jurors about the excavations of
soil taken from around ruben's home last
year after noticing a change in behavior
from the cadaver dogs
and over in tennessee the man
investigators say abducted and murdered
a memphis mother of two is being held
without bond
thirty-eight-year-old cleotha abstinent
appeared in shelby county court on
wednesday for the second arraignment
this week apston was originally charged
with kidnapping and tampering with
evidence but was later charged with
first degree murder when fletcher's body
was found during wednesday's court
appearance the case's judge revoked
abstinence bond that had previously been
set at five hundred thousand dollars
investigators say 34 year old fletcher
was last seen alive on friday september
2nd just after four o'clock in the
morning officials say she was out for a
run when she was forced into a black suv
and taken away investigators later
confirmed apston was driving that
vehicle he was arrested on saturday and
charged in connection to fletcher's
disappearance on monday memphis area
investigators discovered a body near
where appston was seen cleaning out his
vehicle
on tuesday investigators confirmed that
that body belonged to fletcher so far a
cause of death has not been made public
abstinence due back in court again on
thursday
marie at first bond was set at 500 000
but that was revoked when the murder
charge was added is it common for a
judge to do this to revoke bail
absolutely based on the nature of the
evidence that's mounting against him and
it seems like the evidence is
unrefutable they have him on video they
recovered the vehicle i'm sure they have
a plethora of dna evidence against him
revoking that bail was
in order the judge had to do it so if
you look at that terry right and you
think about all the evidence against him
and you think about if he's convicted of
everything across the board what does he
face in terms of prison time
listen i think they're going to throw
the book at him he has a criminal record
he was actually accused of rape when he
was a teenager he has served 20 years
for violently kidnapping a prosecutor of
all people doing his or her job that is
something that is very serious he was
definitely let out of jail after serving
the time and you can argue that it's
only fair that you allow someone after
they've served their time to get out of
jail but here we see that he's
committing really heinous crimes again
he's been charged with multiple crimes
he was charged with especially
aggravated kidnapping which is more in
tennessee than just regular kidnapping
you can actually get up to 60 years you
can get 15 to 60 years that's a lot of
time and one of the other charges was
tampering with evidence which is
obviously one of the minor charges and
he could also get life without parole or
death for the murder charge and i think
the prosecution here is going to seek
the maximum there's no question that
they want this man behind bars they
don't want to have him get out again
with the possibility that he could
commit yet another crime and we know he
already did so i anticipate at the end
of the day if there's a conviction and
we have every reason to believe like
when we said there's a ton of evidence
here that there will be a conviction i
think that unless there's a plea deal
right you're going to see a request for
death it is chilling and we'll be
curious to see if he actually takes a
plea deal or if this will head to trial
marie terry thank you both so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you